tu as sûrement vu ces images de faux
supporters qui défilent au Qatar voici
ce que l'on sait sur ces vidéos on voit
des centaines de femmes qui encouragent
le Brésil le Portugal l'Allemagne ou
encore l'Argentine à Doha mais de
nombreuses personnes doutent de leur
véritable nationalité la presse
britannique affirme même que ces
derniers ont été payés en cherchant on
peut voir que ces fans semblent
participer à la communication de la
Coupe du Monde du Qatar ils sont pour la
plupart d'origine indiennes et aurait
été sélectionnées pour rejoindre un fan
club chacun porte alors le maillot d'une
équipe pour ensuite défiler et mettre
l'ambiance toutes les pages Instagram de
ces fan club ont été créés au début de
l'été et avant ses premiers défilés on
voit bien qu'aucun contenu ne laisse
penser que ces personnes étaient déjà
fan de ces équipes ici cette jeune fille
est fan du Brésil puis de la France et
enfin du Qatar et quelques jours avant
de supporter le Brésil ce jeune homme
posé avec tout l'attirail de
l'organisation pour autant le Qatar ne
semble pas s'en cacher puisqu'il est
assez facile de se rendre compte de
cette mascarade c'est une nouvelle
polémique qui intervient à six jours du
début du Mondial alors que les appels au
boycott se sont multipliés ces dernières
semaines